it is nearly 20 years since the end of
the 1992-1995
or a conflict whose far-reaching impact
continues to influence policymakers
today the massive intention destruction
of cultural and religious property
during the war targeting
bosnia-herzegovina 'he's historically
diverse identity was one of its defining
features and prompted an urgent
reassessment of how cultural property
could be protected in times of conflict
later prosecutions against those held
responsible for the attacks led to a
more definitive recognition in
international humanitarian law the
destruction of a people's cultural
heritage was not only a crime in itself
but also a manifestation of persecution
and genocide especially in the trials
carried out the International Criminal
Tribunal for the former Yugoslavia
initiated by bosnian serbs separatist
Bosnian Serbs aided by Serbia following
bosnia's declaration of independence
from yugoslavia the conflict pitted
separatist Bosnian Serb and later
bosnian croat forces against the
internationally recognized government of
bosnia-herzegovina labeled by many
commentators and politicians as muslim
as in the Muslim army or the Muslim led
government which did not help when
trying to get aid going to Bosnia yet
the Bosnian war was not considered a
religious one although those can
promoting the conflict certainly
mobilized the past and ethno national
and ethnic religious differences above
all it was characterized by the practice
of ethnic cleansing to create ethnically
homogenous areas so here's archons
Tigers in Vienna 1992 and in a mosque
the ethnic cleansing was characterized
above all by the expulsion of targeted
groups interment in concentration camps
mass murder torture mass rape and the
destruction of the religious and
cultural symbols of the expelled
population also notorious were the long
siege of sarajevo by bosnian serb forces
during which the national library was
targeted and the extensive devastation
of mas dark this is the interior of the
library and the extensive devastation of
Masdar particularly during fighting
between bosnian croat and bosnian
government
troops over 1993 when the Ottoman old
bridge was destroyed during three and a
half years of war over two million
people almost half the country's
population were displaced I became
refugees nearly 100,000 people were
killed and thousands of monuments of
cultural and religious importance were
destroyed or badly damaged yet
throughout the conflict there was a
large United Nations multinational
peacekeeping force and international
humanitarian aid presence in Bosnia
that's the center of sorry well that's
the National Museum there were two
openly voiced aims in this destruction
of cultural and religious property first
to obliterate and remove from the
landscape the material evidence of the
expelled communities historic roots on
the territory and second by destroying
these symbols of community identity to
discourage the expelled populations from
ever returning thus the destruction was
identified quite unmistakeably by
perpetrators and international observers
alike as being an intrinsic part of the
process of ethnic cleansing by the end
of the war for instance with one
exception not a single intact minaret
was left standing in areas occupied by
bosnian serb forces who controlled
seventy percent of the territory of
bosnia herzegovina and here is the imam
of the mosque after the war showing a
picture of the wasp before the war and
its remains in 2000 before and after
this is the serbian orthodox cathedral
top right and after the defining
characteristics of the attack on
cultural and religious property is that
they were intentional and systematic
that the greater part of the destruction
occurred as a result of deliberate
targeting and the most occurred far from
the front lines or after fighting had
ceased and areas were insecure control
of the perpetrators the types of built
heritage destroyed or badly damaged were
overwhelming religious and all
whelming the ottoman or associated with
muslims though there was also
destruction and damage to the catholic
crore orthodox herb heritage also
targeted were structures with no ethnic
national and affiliation but which
symbolized or held evidence of bosnia's
historic diversity such as museums
archives libraries and institutions like
the Oriental Institute in Sarajevo thus
the destruction can be seen as an
assault on the physical evidence of a
historic coexistence and heterogeneity
in Bosnian Serb control Banja Luka where
there were no military operations at any
time 15 marks 12 of which were listed
monuments were destroyed and this was
the fair idea before its destruction
after its destruction the then the site
was leveled and the remains taken to the
municipal garbage dump this is the
retrieving of the remains at Rami Chi in
2005 and how the site looked in 2005
before restoration reconstruction began
this is the allergy mosque in faccia
before and it this is a satellite
picture which was used at the war crimes
tribunal in october 91 on the right you
can still see the minaret on august 92
on the this is of the allergy on the
right you can see there's just an empty
space and that was the site of the
mosque in 1996 this was a Catholic
Church which suffered the same fate and
this was the fate of most of these sites
mostly of mosques they became places
where cars were parked garbage were
dumped sometimes structures were built
on them this is just after the ethnic
cleansing of faccia this mosque in the
background the sarva these were the
remains in 2000 where I found them and
occasionally mosque rubble was used to
cover the mass graves of Muslims here is
that for cha on war crimes in
the Gators were excavating mass grave
site and found remains of the allergen
mosque but what actions did the
international community taken
confronting in the fest's addressing the
devastation of cultural property in
Bosnia it was very clear that
international legal instruments for
protecting cultural heritage in times of
conflict conflict just didn't work and
there were you know the UN troops
stationed across the country but they
still couldn't stop it happening but in
other respects unfortunately despite a
flood of statements resolutions and
appeals some policy making and an
eruption of symposia on disaster
preparedness most international heritage
bodies including UNESCO icomos and I
calm seemed unable or unwilling to offer
help where help was needed and being
desperately worked for in Bosnia itself
in terms of perhaps technical assistance
emergency aid and even for information
the director-general of unesco
encouraged NGOs to step in where he led
UNESCO was not able to operate but this
simply didn't happen and the tiny
organization I worked for the HHR was
the only heritage NGO working in Bosnia
throughout the entire conflict the
Parliamentary Assembly of the Council of
Europe was the only international
organization to take any form of action
in respect of the Heritage sending
consultant experts to assess the
destruction in 10 information reports
that they hope would galvanize the
international community international
conservation community into taking
action to protect the Heritage that
remained and political action to stop
the damage happening of what they called
the report called a cultural catastrophe
in the heart of Europe unfortunately
these hopes were largely unrealized the
reports however raised early on what was
rarely achieved and probably not even
today the need to integrate support for
the cultural heritage into other
humanitarian aid activities and the
importance of giving emergency technical
assistance before the conflict ended
they urged international actors to
beware of behind in false reasons for
not intervening at under
stage nor to feel ashamed of being
concerned for the cultural heritage
while people were suffering pointing out
the socio-economic psychological
dimensions of the destruction so here we
clearly see the paradox of cultural
property protection in times of conflict
even though international humanitarian
law clearly mandates protection of a
people's cultural property concerns over
being seen to be privileged encoder
people remain problematic for
international bodies even though it's
concerned with heritage perfection thus
there was very little assistance to
protect Bosley's cultural heritage
during the war with a few notable assist
exceptions such as Italian aid to
restore domed mosques and master yet
much could have been done for example to
help museums and their workers to
protect their collections most of which
survived the destruction small-scale
efforts usually work better than large
ones and with ingenuity persistence
supplies got through even if some were
lost and vital links were maintained
with the outside world after the signing
of the Dayton Agreement in December 1995
this marked the end of the war and
bosnia's division into two entities the
federation of bosnia herzegovina the
so-called Muslim Croat federation and
the serb dominated republika srpska with
an international appointed civilian
hyper that presented of one of whom we
have clear today wolfgang petrich who
with a nato-led multinational military
force was responsible for implementing
the peace treaty which focused above all
on the effects reversing the effects of
ethnic cleansing uniquely Dayton rate
recognized the rule cultural heritage
destruction had played during the
conflict and among the treaties 11
annexes annex a mandated the
establishment of a commission to
preserve national monuments which former
High Representative Wolfgang patridge
will discuss later on in more detail
thus restoration and preservation of
destroys Bosley's destroyed and damaged
historic monuments should have taken
place within a particular framework the
return of refugees and displaced people
under the terms of the Dayton Agreement
to the homes and community
from which they had been forcibly
expelled and to attempt to restore
bosnia-herzegovina diverse pre-war
society and I got time discipline I just
want to finish I was but I didn't think
I'd have time to say was that a huge
proportion of the aid for restoration in
Bosnia went to master which was badly
damaged and was terrible but it sucked
up most of the available funding this is
the reconstructed or bridge and it
became a kind of you know obsession of
the bridge is a symbol the bridges with
symbol of reconciliation mine G is where
as in Republic of Srpska this orb syrup
dominated part of Bosnia where they were
returning refugees this is where most
restoration actually was going on and it
was almost entirely a community-based
never got any assistance of the
international community at all because
they were basically afraid to operate in
Republic of Srpska so here's some men
years Zbornak restored restoring the
turbo of a shake this is this was funded
by community look who were based all
over the world but they would send
donations to reveal the mosque this is
the optics mosque near palana this
little mosque Reza did was rebuilt even
though no Muslims returned to this area
of Republic of Srpska but they wanted to
many wanted to be buried there as you
can see in the graveyard and they also
wanted to show that Muslims had lived on
this territory so even though none had
gone back there they still rebuilt this
little miss Jade mosque without a
minaret I think this is install outs and
I just want to finish with this example
of how aid from the international
community could have been given now this
is the fogger the mac med Pasha cook of
it's a mosque one of them domed mosques
in in Bosnia now in Republic of Srpska
bosnian serb dominated territory it was
surrounded you can see by many historic
buildings there's the hon over on the
but it was almost destroyed during the
war this is in 2000's now this was the
sole domed mosque structure left in
Republicans the territory of republika
srpska in 2000 after the war when there
was a huge international presence in
Bosnia it could have been given
emergency protection the Republic of
Srpska heritage people would not have
been interested or wouldn't of being
permitted to do anything here the the
Bosnian one was not allowed to which had
been the state institute for protection
of monuments before the war wasn't
allowed to operate in public a service
got it so nothing was done in 2004 there
was a storm and the dome collapsed so by
2008 when the Commission to preserve
national monuments formed under the
Dayton Agreement was allowed to operate
there and they receive funding from the
US ambassador's fund for culture they
gave the now very long overdue emergency
protection to this structure so for a
bit of basic protection in two thousand
five years after the end of the war this
structure would still be there now it's
just basically a wall thank you
you